there's nothing but love for the cast of
the Jersey Shore our family vacation
only we joined them for an Italian
dinner where it's clear that despite all
the drama this family is forever
[Music]
Angelina how many plates you have two
it's hard to get all of us in the same
room we're missing a couple soldiers
right now one of those soldiers Mike the
situation Sorrentino currently serving
an eight month sentence for tax evasion
I got the chills thinking about he'll be
released in September but his friends
say he's making the most of it
Mike so really I think he's doing great
he eats well he goes to the gym twice a
day he gets a haircut twice a week eight
hours sleep like he looks like refreshed
another thing we learned during our
family dinner at Patsy's Italian
restaurant JWoww son three-year-old
Grayson who was diagnosed with autism is
progressing by leaps and bounds he's
gone from not speaking to attempting
full sentences
speaking about anything especially like
autism can break this stigma so I just
want to make the world a little less
harsh and more sweet so when he goes to
school they'll be less critics and
actually like more people that want to
help Snooki just welcome to baby number
three Angelo in May and like JWoww their
daughters are following in mom's
footsteps they're literally yeah our
daughters are literally spitting images
Ben yeah it's weird
we love this pic of Snooki when she was
her daughter's age but you know what
we'd love even more the cast playing
never have I ever been kicked out of a
bar okay all of us then walk in on by
the kids while having sex mommies
wrestling watch the Jersey Shore episode
with my parents Wow that's where we draw
the line then drunk at work that's our
job never have you ever your family
vacation returns tonight on MTV
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]